uh what i will say is
if i have anything to do with
any other music we definitely have
understanding that there's no uh
disrespecting anybody
dead homies or uh any artist in
particular you know what i'm saying
whatever i touch gotta be just music
and i think really he's at a point in
his career where he shouldn't have to do
that anymore anyway so you guys you
pretty much have an agreement with him
that if you do get involved on the music
side that the disrespect has to
anything i touch
i mean i don't know he might go do some
other random [ __ ] that's his business i
can't control that but if i'm touching
it
right it can't it can't be you know i
mean you talking about you know
somebody's dead right [ __ ] like that i'm
really not off into that so
is that something that you think is
going to end up happening where you're
kind of like
helping him out on the music side
um i've i've looked at his contracts
because i needed to understand that um
um
was what
you know what i mean because it's a lot
of things that goes along with you know
publishing deals and and things of that
nature he still signed who he signed to
right you know that's still they
business you know but i will look at his
contract
because if he has any questions about
what's going on or what's not going on i
need to be able to answer that